rudy giuliani is now reportedly
panicking
and his priority is to die a free man to
die a free man
that doesn't sound like things are going
particularly well
rudy giuliani is now being forced to
appear
before a georgia grand jury
investigating the trump and associates
attempts to overturn the results in
november of 2020 results in which joe
biden won georgia let me say that in a
very clear way joe biden won georgia so
joe biden should have gotten and did get
the electoral votes from georgia however
donald trump and rudy giuliani and jenna
ellis and a whole bunch of different
people lindsey graham were to different
degrees and in different ways lobbying
for trump to get those electoral votes
that would have been wrong rudy giuliani
now has to appear before a grand jury he
tried to having his lawyers say he can't
travel
rudy travels all the time didn't make
any sense judge didn't buy it he is
arguably going to try to say that
everything he did was as the lawyer for
trump and therefore it's protected by
attorney-client privilege but it doesn't
seem like it's necessarily going to work
but we now are being told
that rudy is concerned that he may not
die a free man that is very very serious
like ken i want to start with you sure
as someone who worked for rude giuliani
john did also but you were regionalized
press secretary the target now
of this investigation that's a big deal
it's a big deal and he's trying to
create a smoke screen and delay as long
as possible listen rudy flew too close
to the sun he got too close to trump he
got burned
um he knows how do he flew too close to
the sun on the wings of mega trumpism
and you can't do that and avoid getting
burned forever jay works he knows how
the fbi works he knows these are
meticulous
investigations i i know this is not a
popular position with the media but i
think we should take a wait and see
um
uh that the affidavit shouldn't be
released i'm doubling back to the
earlier conversation
um i know he's i know he's nervous uh he
could have flown uh to georgia uh you
know he flies all over the world yep so
that's just a typical uh tactic to try
to postpone the inevitable why do you
think he's nervous about this georgia
investigation because he know he knows
the truth he knows he lied to
legislators he knows that he concocted
this false elector scheme
um
you know he knows he lied for his client
and he knows we all know it's it's clear
what's his next move
at delay delay delay kick the can down
the road i think you know at this point
in his life
his goal is to
die a free man can you imagine
look at how quickly rudy who was mayor
911 beloved by everybody even many
democrats
and all of a sudden it's
am i gonna die in prison or am i going
to die a free man
pretty stark john that is stark and look
it highlights i think the tragedy
of his trajectory um but it's a
self-inflicted tragedy you know the deal
is that rudy was as ken knows really one
of the most respected legal minds of his
generation i remember him telling me
many times that you know the law is
about to search for the truth and that
is not what he is is is pursuing right
now trying to evade the truth um because
he's afraid of of what will will come up
now he is saying look i was acting in
the capacity as lawyer and whether
ex-president ultimately throws him under
the bus is yet to be seen but i will
also say that rudy giuliani is someone
who said many times on tape from the
blue room at city hall that you know you
respect the sanctity of a grand jury
they know more than we do and so to push
back against that as aggressively as he
has and to throw around terms like
fascist state is beneath the man he was
and the credibility he once had to be
clear bernard about
the luck he's going to have pursuing
this yes delay but success probably not
i mean the judge has said fake electors
you have to comply yep congressman jody
heist you have to comply
senator graham you have to show up
exactly so with rudy giuliani you can
run but you can't hide your time is up
you have now graduated to being a target
and now it's your time to appear before
this grand jury he complete the fifth
yes he can decide oh attorney client
privilege but then you have the crime
fraud exception but there's so much that
can go on so bottom line here
it's sort of a sad tale about rudy
giuliani in a sense i mean on a personal
level it is sad you've got a guy who's i
think 76 77 years old something like
that
he did have even though he was not my
political preference he did have a good
career prosecuting the mafia followed by
being mayor of 911 and after nine uh the
mayor of 911 the mayor of new york city
during 9 11 the mayor of 9 11 sounds
really bad the mayor of new york city
during 9 11 widely seen as was george w
bush as participating in sort of
bringing the nation together and
handling it well and then it started to
get a little weird where rudy would not
stop talking about 911 no matter what
the question was for years after he was
mayor and then he attached his wagon to
trump's horse
and that is a hell of a horse to attach
your wagon to and it is self-inflicted
so it can be both sad and also correct
that rudy now has to deal with this he
did things that he knew or were
the wrong things to do in terms of
telling lies etc and he's going to have
to face the consequences these clips are
all on our instagram which you can find
by searching instagram for david pakman
show
as many of you know i'm a busy person i
don't always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time-consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high quality vitamins and
minerals and my probiotics and it's all
from whole food sources i drink it in
the morning i know i'm good i don't have
to be messing around with different
pills and supplements or whatever or
spend time planning it when what time of
day do i need to take each one i just
get it all with one scoop you can put it
in a smoothie you can drink it straight
it tastes great and then i'm just good
for the day it supports gut health and
i'm getting everything that i need and
i'm looking for athletic greens is
giving my audience a free one-year
supply of vitamin d plus five free
travel packs when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below